او اشير الى هذه الصور التي نتابعها الان
مع مشاهدينا الصور مباشره للدمار الناجم
عن الزلزال في مدينه حلب كما شاهدنا في
الخبر العاجل قبل قليل نقلا عن مراسل
العربيه الذي اشار الى ان عدد القتلى في
سوريا وصل الى
1604 اشخاص
الزلزال مشاهدينا في سوريا ضرب مناطق
سيطره النظام ايضا ضرب محافظات حلب
واللاذقيه وحمى وطرطوس هناك جهود كبيره
يقوم بها السكان ويقوم بها تقوم بها فرق
محليه
للاغاثه للبحث تحت الانقاط لعل وعسى ان
تكون هناك بعض الحالات التي ما زالت على
قيد الحياه محاوله انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه
في هذه اللحظات الصعبه سوريا تعاني طبعا
بالتاكيد ولا تحظى بنفس الكم من المساعدات
التي وصلت الى تركيا المناطق النظام بعض
المراقبين الذين صدفناهم في خلال نشاط
السابقه تحدثوا عن ان
فرق الانقاذ المتواجده في مناطق النظام
ربما تكون اكثر حرفيه لديها خبرات عده
لديها معدات اكبر لكن مناطق الشمال السوري
او شمال غرب سوريا او مناطق المعارضه لا
تحظى بذات القدر من الامكانات المتوفره
لدى مناطق اخرى في سوريا